que alexis poulain cofondateur du monde
moderne alexis bollart merci d'être avec
nous sur ert france alors pour commencer
est ce que le gouvernement aurait pu
accepter pour le 1er mai des
rassemblements avec bien entendu le
respect des consignes sanitaires est ce
que cela aurait peut être quelque chose
de faisable ou en tout cas veut
symbolique oui bien sûr c'était quelque
chose de tout à fait faisable on a vu
des manifestations de ce type en israël
où les distances de sécurité étaient
respectées manifestations contre la
corruption des gouvernants donc c'est un
choix volontaire de dire on fait le
choix de la précaution bien entendu en
une fois encore ne faisant pas confiance
aux uns et aux autres de respecter les
gestes barrière alors les syndicats qui
ont rencontré edouard philippe
aujourd'hui si vous vous remettre
rapidement les français au travail
quelles garanties doivent être assurés
bien les garanties c'est de préserver
les droits des travailleurs parce qu'on
a vu ces dernières semaines des attaques
en règle de la part des syndicats
patronaux le medef en tête pour casser
les 35 heures pour faire en sorte que et
bien finalement les les jours de congés
soit diminuée pour sauver l'économie
française avec ce rêve de semaine de
travail de 60 heures pourquoi pas dans
les secteurs clés donc vraiment d'une
poussée du syndicat patronal pour
essayer de casser encore davantage le
code et le droit du travail et puis
l'autre chose aussi où il faut être
vigilant
c'est que le ministère du travail ne
soutient pas les inspecteurs du travail
il y à une pétition qui tourne en ce
moment pour soutenir un inspecteur du
travail qui a été mise à pied pour
simplement faire son travail et dire que
il est salarié d'une entreprise n'était
pas protégé lorsque celle ci était en
activité au pic de la crise le ministère
du travail ça doit devenir le ministère
des travailleurs ce qui va se passer
avec le déconfinement ce que montre ce
virus c'est que la lutte des classes n'a
jamais été aussi vivace n'a jamais été
d'une telle intensité
il ya ceux qui sont en première ligne
les invisibles ceux qui ne sont rien
selon emmanuel macron à kiel dit merci
quotidiennement les caissiers les
éboueurs les gens qui sont là qui font
tenir cette économie
parce qu'il ne manque de rien et qu'il
travaille au quotidien ces gens là quand
la crise sera finie et bien ce sera une
ligne sur un tableau excel et les
décideurs les néo manager les managers
et bien les dires rond pour sauver les
profits des actionnaires
donc il est important que les syndicats
soient conscients que aujourd'hui plus
que jamais la lutte des classes est
d'actualité et qu'ils sont responsables
pour tenir les droits des travailleurs
face à une attaque sans précédent des de
ces droits là alors il ya des syndicats
qui ont grandi la carte du droit de
retrait notamment concernant la
réouverture dans les écoles est ce qu'un
mouvement pourra imaginer qu'un
mouvement social finalement s'invite
dans la stratégie du déconfinement
évidemment je pense c'est la peur même
de l'exécutif
imaginez un déconfinement politique
imaginez un déconfinement sociale et
solidaire imaginaire déconfinement avec
des procès pour leur responsabilité dans
cette gestion calamiteuse de la crise
vouloir mettre les français au travail
très bien parce que derrière évidemment
on ne peut pas accepter la faillite de
40% de restaurants où vient la faillite
de pme en france mais pas à n'importe
quel prix
je pense que c'est extrêmement important
que les syndicats jouent le rôle à plein
c'est à dire de protéger les droits des
travailleurs parce que l'économie ne
doit pas être fait aux dépens des
travailleurs c'est eux qui sont les
créateurs de valeur c'est eux par leur
travail par le quotidien qui font que ce
atone qui font que eh bien les rentiers
peuvent bénéficier de leur rente
il faut simplement rééquilibrer regardez
la folie idéologique de ce gouvernement
qui refuse de remettre lisf sur la table
qui refuse de faire payer les plus
riches leur part juste au gâteau en
disant vous avez bénéficié de ce système
c'est à vous maintenant de redonner au
commun et qui préfèrent vendre et bien
les bijoux de famille avec le mobilier
national et autres pour trouver un peu
d'argent pour l'hôpital
on est dans un scandale idéologiques
sans fin son nom et là ma peur est la
peur de beaucoup c'est que cette sortie
de crise en fête ouvre les vannes en
fait dernier au libéralisme encore plus
violent que ce qu'on a connu auparavant
où finalement la captation du profit et
l'exploitation des uns par les autres
ben va être encore plus violente que
auparavant merci beaucoup avec six
poulains je rappelle que vous êtes co
fondateur du monde moderne